the worst thing about Ted Cruz is that
his biggest accomplishment happened a
while ago he has nothing else to show
for his time in office yeah there's no
real program of what is going to do
going forward he's a sense hitch to the
fact that that was his big
accomplishment he can give a really
really really good speech yeah but you
move from outside his comfort zone and
he doesn't sound very good doesn't sound
like the debate champion we all think he
think he is so so he's basically a you
know he's a he's a teddy onenote
theoretically and and that's the people
associating with the government shutdown
and I think there will be enough
Republican primary voters you get to the
larger states Michigan New York Florida
were there more delegates at stake who
understand that you can't run against
the government in that way yeah and
that's going to crush Ted Cruz do you
think it'll also hurt him that he was so
aligned with repealing Obamacare which
he still wants to repeal but it seems to
me that whether it has fully worked the
way people wanted a to or not that
people more people have health insurance
right now and ultimately that's not a
winning move you know I go back and
forth about in the Republican primary
what Obamacare is going to do the public
at large it's not gonna be an issue
anymore yeah in the Republican primary
there's a lot of voters really energized
them to say Obamacare is you know the
worst thing since as another candidate
said you know the Dred Scott decision
but I don't know that that the successes
and there's certainly lots of problems
with Obamacare the successes of
Obamacare are are fairly astounding and
they are greater than the Obama people
thought they would be it's harder and
harder to say that Obamacare's is the
worst thing the worst thing ever since
rotten and slice